CNN rang in the New Year was something
rarely if ever seen on national news a
reporter holding a joint in lighting a
bong the network's New Year's Eve
coverage included several live shots
from reporter Randi Kaye in Denver who
reminded viewers that marijuana use is
legal in Colorado listen now I came
prepared you know this year I thought
maybe I would bring a gas mask with me
so I wouldn't you know get that contact
high but look what's on the other end of
the gas mask yes a bong you patty right
okay okay so you're gonna now what now
you're gonna celebrate a little New
Year's earlier what is with you I've
never hit fun oh right okay this I don't
think this is really what a gas mask is
used for but oh my god Brandi's doses
kick Andy Andy this is for you no total
dopes I'm sorry
dope smoking dope a group called mothers
of children affected by marijuana call
CNN's coverage a free infomercial for
big weed joining me now from Columbus
Ohio is a member of that group
Corrine Gasper Corrine a guy was happily
on the dance floor on New Year's Eve and
dancing the night away with friends and
and others and I didn't watch a minute
of television I'm glad I didn't but you
as a mother who lost a child to someone
impaired while taking medical marijuana
I can't imagine your reaction to seeing
that it was very outrageous to see what
I would call would be irresponsible
journalism and on behalf of CNN well
they're saying look is all fun and games
Corrine you know it's legal no it's
illegal in Colorado it's a federal crime
by the way still but it's legal in
Colorado and it's now legal in
California they did big ribbon-cutting
ceremonies and lovely little moments all
over television that night
tell us about your own
families tragedy as difficult as it is
if you don't mind sure my daughter
Jennifer had just graduated from college
she was just 22 years old on the verge
of a wonderful career she wanted to
actually go out in the world and fight
drugs she began her first job not in her
field of study but she was called in to
work as a district manager into one of
the stores when an alarm went off as
Jennifer made her way in
she was t-boned at an intersection by a
man who was travelling 82 miles an hour
through a red light my daughter's car
was pushed across a road through a bunch
of shrubbery shrubbery and then through
the the doors of a lude stop building
and the building collapsed on top of her
car my daughter lost her life that night
the man that did this was uninjured but
he was high on medical marijuana he was
given a very light sentence of just two
years in jail he only spent 17 months
there and now we're out and he's off
parole as it's infuriating and all we
hear about is how marijuana is the only
thing you can take to ease pain and that
anyone criticizing it is heartless and
by the way according Newsweek attacked
me and I don't really care but I mean I
said where is a badge of honor but
basically for having a similar reaction
to the CNN coverage as you did I tweeted
out well we'll see how all this works
out for our country more potheads
increase in cases of schizophrenia
psychosis more impaired driving as big
weed makes billions so newsweek ran at
peace with the headline pot panic Fox
News's Laura Ingraham roasted after
criticizing CNN New Year's Eve coverage
well I was hardly roasted they pulled a
few tweets out ooh I'm scared and this
is what they do to you though if you
dare to take on big weed big pot and the
multi billionaires and millionaires that
are funding this effort for legalization
nationwide your comment to mothers who
are seeing this legalization movement
grow nationwide how do how to get
involved given your own loss I can't
imagine I have a daughter who's 12 years
old I can't
it's we don't need anymore to anyone
else dying on the road but indeed we
will have this unfortunately I do think
that we need to contact our senators and
our governors and our state officials
and tell them that we need more
education in this area a lot of people
are filled with misnomers that have been
put out by the the medical I mean you
know the marijuana industry and I
definitely think that we need more
education because this isn't the weed
from back in the 70s this is a very
powerful drug and it causes psychosis
and many other things and people that
smoke it and the more we legalize it the
more younger people are trying it it
early in earlier ages no evidence is
building and growing and I appreciate
you having the courage to come on
tonight and even though even hateful
things are said about you and the
victims of this legalization effort and
I just really appreciate it thank you
some